[Music]
foreign
ER and I'm a lecturer at Stanford's
Graduate School of Business I teach a
course called reputation management
strategies for successful communicators
and I'm going to share the top five tips
from this course that I teach
I believe that your reputation is like
an echo it precedes you into a room and
it's what remains behind after you leave
imagine that someone talks about you
before you show up wait to meet Allison
she's an expert at reputation and she
has amazing tips you're going to love
her well then the audience is going to
be predisposed to like me and appreciate
me even before I get to the room
and then what is said after I leave the
room is equally as important
things like wow she really did a great
job or I loved how funny she was or
those tips are excellent I've got to
introduce her to somebody
that's how your reputation can get you
new business opportunities and new
contacts it's not just your primary
audience that you're affecting with your
reputation it's your secondary and your
tertiary audiences it's how someone
talks about you and then it gets passed
on and passed on and that is why your
reputation can really help you if it's a
good one to start with
Jesus
[Music]
if you or your company is experiencing a
negative reputation issue I recommend
that you follow Daniel dearmeyer's trust
radar which is out of his book
reputation roles this framework is
excellent for reputation recovery
this Raider has four axes and at the top
of it is empathy and what this means is
that the first step is that you show
empathy for whoever feels that they were
harmed or hurt by this reputation issue
and you take full accountability and you
show that you're very sorry for the hurt
that was caused
to the right of the radar is
transparency and this means you can't
say no comment it means you have to give
context to why what happened happened
and also take accountability but explain
what was involved on the bottom of the
radar is expertise and this means that
you are going to put whoever is the most
appropriate person and they're going to
take the responsibility to fix this and
finally when the left side of the axes
is commitment and this means you're
committed to making sure everything gets
fixed the way it should and providing a
timetable so people know what the
expectations are
if you can hit all these four axes of
the trust radar then you can repair a
reputation
[Music]
add reputation there is a way to change
it and what I always say is behave your
way out of it and what I love about that
is you're never stuck in a reputation
reputation is fluid so take for example
if maybe you're chronically late
and everybody thinks it's funny and
quirky at the beginning but after a
while it starts to get annoying and then
people think you're being very
disrespectful and it becomes this fixed
bias against you you can't just say you
know what I'm going to start showing up
early no one will believe you you have
no credibility so what I suggest is you
show up 10 minutes early for every
meeting so the first meeting you're
going to show up 10 minutes early and
people are going to be like what are you
doing here you're early and you'll say I
know I'm going to be early from now on
and they're going to roll their eyes and
say sure
then you're going to come to the next
meeting 10 minutes early and they're
going to say oh still doing that early
thing huh and you're going to say yep
I'm going to be early every time but
you'll see by the time you get to the
fourth or fifth meeting that you've
shown up early all of a sudden that bad
reputation is going to fade and this new
behavior is going to become your norm
and that is how you can change your
reputation by behaving your way out of
it
[Music]
my favorite reputation Mantra is it's
not what happens it's how you choose to
deal with it because let's face it
things happen in life their difficulties
their challenges but it's not what
happens to you it's how you choose to
deal with it that really sets your
reputation apart you can make something
a moment of disaster or a moment of
Triumph
Tylenol Scandal of 1982 as an example
someone got into some Tylenol bottles in
Chicago and people were poisoned by
Cyanide and died it was a terrible
terrible scandal
but what Tylenol did was really amazing
they took complete accountability they
never tried to point the blame at a
random killer they said this is our
medicine and we're going to take
everything off the shelves we're going
to give your money back
and what they did is they actually
created camper proof
lit all of their medicines
returning this moment of disaster into a
moment of impact and as a result in all
their future products they would
actually put a little catchphrase that
said by the makers of Tylenol because
everybody knew that Tylenol had a
reputation for commitment caring and
safety
businesses
when you are a leader at work you are a
role model to everybody else and your
reputation is a signal of how you're
going to lead
and imagine that someone has bad
behavior and you're the leader and maybe
it is actually your boss or it's
somebody who is an employee but they're
confronting you they're challenging you
they're yelling at you they're blaming
you
what I suggest is instead of rising to
their anger you sit back you take a
breath and you show compassion and
empathy and patience
they are looking for a fight and so when
you don't rise to the occasion and meet
your antagonist where he or she wants
you basically take the wind out of their
sails and then if you show compassion
and say Hey you look really upset what's
going on or wow something's bothering
you how can I help you
you just change the whole dynamic but
the important thing to remember is don't
let someone else's bad behavior
affect the kind of leader you are
their behavior should not define you
stay in control and be the best version
of yourself and you will have a very
strong leadership reputation
[Music]
foreign
I have two teenage boys and believe it
or not they are so proud of me however
if I say something that they don't like
or they pretend they don't want to hear
they'll say well you didn't communicate
that very well and that's a shame
because you're a communication expert
double-edged sword I say
[Music]